the singer r kelly's been sentenced to
30 years in prison for creating a scheme
to entice and sexually exploit young
aspiring singers and underage children
the r b star was convicted in september
of racketeering and sex trafficking our
correspondent joe pike is in new york
where the sentencing just took place and
joe they were seeking 25 years or more
they got 30.
they certainly did a wilfred r kelly is
55 years old therefore he will be
in his mid-80s by the time he could
escape jail he therefore may die in jail
the judge
alison donnelly said there were few
crimes more serious than serial rape and
sexual abuse over many years r kelly
used his entourage of staff bodyguards
assistants managers to procure young
boys and girls to control them sexually
abuse them and also to threaten them so
they did not
speak out he has been sitting in court
with dark glasses wearing a
khaki shirt and sitting and listening as
his victims have described him as
disgusting and despicable
one said he was a pied piper who lured
children with his money and celebrity
with every addition of a new victim you
grew in wickedness one said you used
your fame and power to groom and coach
underage boys and girls for your own
sexual gratification another victim
broke down in tears as she took
talked about the impact of that abuse on
her life and on her mental health then
in a poignant moment her father stood up
to address the court i didn't come here
to bash mr kelly he said i do want to
ask you mr kelly to look at me man to
man father to father put yourself in my
shoes i've certainly put myself in your
shoes but r kelly did not look up his
lawyers had been pushing for a 10-year
sentence citing his difficult childhood
and the fact that he himself was a
victim of sexual abuse when he was young
but clearly the judge rejected that
giving him
this 30 year sentence
two dynamics have really been
particularly horrifying in this case one
that r kelly
continued with this abuse for so many
years and it was almost an open secret
that he was a predator some argue that
those within the music industry were
complicit because they knew
they were benefiting financially from
his the success of his musical career
another dynamic some of the victims have
touched upon is around race many of the
women most of the of the women that r
kelly abused were black and some of them
believed the color of their skin meant
that their voices were not heard their
stories were not believed well now
finally they have we expect to hear from
some of those victims and their lawyers
when they come out of the court in the
next half hour or so but as one of the
victims
said in court today
you r kelly are dangerous at whatever
age he will be out of court out of
prison uh perhaps when he's in his
mid-80s but he now faces a 30-year term
and there are more charges he's facing
at least two u.s states wilfred so his
legal ballot battles are far from over